okay jesse for all those bachelor fans  what do we have to look forward to is  clayton gonna end up with his person or  is it all gonna fall apart i do sense a  cliffhanger is it all gonna just blow up  and nobody's gonna get that final voice  that's the crazy part we actually still  don't know what's going to happen you  don't have to tell me who if it was up  to you that you would pick for clayton  and is he listening uh it's selective  here  and do the fans have a favorite i think  honestly right now it's really opening i  think it could be rachel it could be  gabby well as they say in the song it's  the final countdown thank you jesse  who's gonna get that rose